in the dogon village of comecon in mali
preparations are underway for rare event
the village dama Damas can be held only
after a good harvest and in this
environment that doesn't happen very
often the Dhamma is a mask festival that
honors deceased elders it is more than a
celebration the Dhamma is a door to
Dogon manhood to wear a mask and dance
at a Dhamma is what every boy lives for
without the Dhamma young men can feel
suspended between boyhood and manhood
this is the case for ultimate Ovilus i
who is 29 but doesn't yet consider
himself a man if you're not initiated
you're not a whole man you thought to be
a bit like a woman that's why the Dhamma
is so important to us
autumn a is from another dogon village
where his grandfather is the oldest man
in the village the revered keeper of the
masks it's his responsibility to
determine the timing of the Dhamma but
there's a conflict some years ago a
spirit told the village fortune-teller
that the next Dhamma would herald the
grandfather's
the last Dhamma in Antony's village was
twenty years ago
hey hey what about doing our boy back in
komak on the whirring song of the
bull-roarer
announces that the celebrations will
soon begin meanwhile autumn a decides to
act he asks the fortune-teller to
contact the spirit that seems to have
condemned him to eternal childhood the
old man is the village shaman and the
figure who predicts the future with him
is the pale Fox the shaman draws
patterns in the sand for the divination
the elusive pale Fox emerges in the cool
of the night looks like he may have his
answer to me the shaman says we'll be
part of a Dhamma with thousands back in
komak on the new day heralds the start
of the ceremony that ought to make an
only dream
every house 1 offers millet to thank the
spirits
the old man of comecon lead the dancing
showing the youngsters how it's done ha
- may may have the Foxes blessing but he
still has to persuade his grandfather
Ottoman knows his quest will benefit all
the young men in his village he implores
his grandfather to initiate the dominant
eventually the old man rule is even
though it may seal his fate the Dhamma
however will not be this year for often
these village Singapore said our new
missus should occur even though the dom
is not this year it will come i will be
allowed to dance I'm so happy this year
to make round millet over
next year it might be him behind the
mask